let's talk about horns uh this uh film
is shot in canada in the winter yes and
i've done some time in canada in the
winter and it is
insanely cold how did you handle that
well
not well um because i the thing i hadn't
been told about it is very cold in
canada and as a solution to that because
they don't want the water to freeze in
the pipes in the trailers overnight they
put antifreeze in it um so it's all like
non-potable water that comes out the tap
i did not know that um so i like drank a
full cup you drank
of non-potable water so i guess like
half antifreeze or whatever it would
have been um and and i didn't know that
that can kill you i guess but but
i don't think it did though but it makes
you stronger no
you were you drank a glass of water
mixed with antifreeze yeah but i didn't
realize that like and then i got just
horrendously ill and didn't know why i
had become so ill and then a couple of
weeks later i went to drink another
glass of water and hair and makeup and
they were like what are you doing don't
do that that's crazy you can't drink
that water um and i just had never seen
the signs which i did i went back and
checked my trailer and there weren't
signs in it that said don't drink this
water so it was it was just uh yeah it
was uh an accident that is that is so
scary to me like how sick did you get
real sick like don't drink antifreeze
my favorite public service announcement
from a celebrity here's daniel radcliffe
with an important mention please don't
drink can't you don't drink candy freeze
it it gives you a bit of a drippy tummy
and i mean what you know it was zippy
time
you know
i just mean like i think there was some
britishism and maybe it is like chutney
on the flub knee
that is actually a much much nicer way
of saying what actually happened it was
it was a i don't want to hear the
british slang for diarrhea i don't want
to hear it it was a disgusting feverish
three days yes
uh okay uh we you got through that you
survived and we're all so happy for that
um you have an american accent in this
movie and uh you're a terrific actor
quite convincing but you had a trick for
mastering an american accent what was
that well my trick from a mastering
american accent came from basically
imitating the wide range of cultural uh
influences that america has had on the
uk um meaning that i just grew up
watching tons of um american shows like
friends and wwf and and stuff like that
but the simpsons was obviously my the
show that i ran home to watch every
night at six o'clock on bbc two so that
was you know i think a huge part of my
american accent is probably just like
a latent bart simpson impressions
you say dude a lot yeah i say dude
actually i do say dude quite a lot in
the film yeah and eat my shorts and
loads of other things he never really
said
it's funny because i i know how popular
that show is across the world and so you
must be i wonder how many kids are
getting their idea of what america is
all about through the simpsons which is
a scary idea is it a scary idea though
like i'd rather have it through the
simpsons than from like reality shows or
anything like that you're right okay
gary springer yeah jerry springer yeah
or i think wwf is another good way to
learn about it
yeah i mean but they're they're all like
we do we are so suffused with american
culture like there's so many like
hit shows that were not hits over here
that gets sold in england as like a
massive american tv show that you're all
gonna love and we just watch it because
we're british and we assume that
anything you make is incredibly cool
so we were saying is we're dumping some
junk on you too you're dumping
everything on us so we get the great
stuff as well yeah but we also get uh
you know other stuff yeah
gotcha say no more yeah we all know what
i'll show you i'm on there now all right
here we go
[Laughter]
this guy's the bee's knees